Điều đang có tiền nhằn giữ lúc này bản sẽ làm gì một số người đã choo mô bạc.
Những ngày qua, đông người dân độ về các cửa hàng bạng bạng trên phủ chình nhân tông khả đổi,
sẽ hàng nhiều dờ để đang kiếm một bạc miếng, dù không có hàng dòng này,
về mua vẫn chấp nhận trở nhận sau 3 đến 6 tháng chỉ cầm trong tay dễ hẹn.
Nêm lại em đến lấy cái lúc mù giới, nè em đợi điểm nhìn ta,
mình đi con sớm của được dễ hẹn,
và đi có dễ tơ đang quan đây đủ đôi,
các cái sống này mình muốn bán ra thì có dễ tơ,
mình bán ra người gặp OK mạng với dờ lấy cao quán,
cái lại xuất của nỗi lên, nó không bạc,
đủ gân hàng thì nó cảm thấp.
Thế tên, trông tối mấy mà cứ bị bất tỷ hồi nơi,
cho nên phải mua đe chánh mất ra hóa.
Cứ đề đầy thôi, nè em không không tình đến chuyện là tăng hề nữa gạm.
Như cửa hàng bạng bạc í dật đông lực hết trở sâu dịch.
Trong phòng tònh qua đi lượng khách khách lột khiến,
có thời gian tăng gốc lối khác,
và vào trong một nè em có thể tạm lửa phòng má trang,
cho đến năm trong lực khác.
Hẹn bạc miếng trong nước được sâu dịch quán móc
30 tư đến tảm bây chụ đồng một kí lâu gạm,
tăng hơn 1 bạc phần trăm trong chưa đầy một tháng.
Các chuyên gia khuyến nghị,
thị trường bạc lâu tư trong nước,
hẹn chỉ có phải giống nhẹp lớn, chếm tị phần.
Người dân nền yêu tiên sâu dịch tại các thương hiệu quý tính,
đàn bảo chất lượng pháp lĩ đồng thời lưu ý khả năng ngô lại khi thì trường biến động
và khi nhiều người cũng mắn ra.